alright so yeah so I guess I'll give the
the the second iteration of this and a
fort and unfortunately it's not nearly
as simple as as the last algorithm so
that that'll be like an open problem to
try and make this simpler so this talk
is going to be about solving the closest
vector problem exactly in two to the end
time and so no already did lattice
definitions so you know here's here's a
lattice I'll just use this notation to
denote the lattice generated by basis B
and this notation for the length of a
basis which is just the the length of
the largest vector in the basis so the
problem that we're just in solving is is
the closest spectral problem this talk
where the difference is we're going to
have a target somewhere in space and our
goal will be to compute the closest
lattice vector to the target and this
problem along with SVP certainly has
quite a few applications and in terms of
hardness the closest vector problem
there's a approximation preserving
reduction from alpha sv p 2 alpha CVP so
CVP sort of harder and in fact in some
sense it's like the hardest lattice
problem among many of the classical
lattice problems so they more or less
all reduced to CVP and you can see that
the how the the hardness transitions is
the approximation factor grows here and
essentially the only thing we know how
to do is in polynomial time is slightly
better than exponential approximations
so what is our main result we're
essentially going to be able to match at
least the you know most significant term
of the last algorithm for solving the
exact closest vector problem and there's
been also i mean the the history of SVP
and CDP are real
we joined at the hip so all of these
methods were applied essentially to both
problems though for the randomized
sitting methods I think you know so
somehow the results aren't quite nearly
as good as they are for SVP because you
you can't get exact solutions and the
the dependence is pretty bad on the
approximation fact okay so let me tell
you the overview so we're going to talk
about how approximate CVP is going to
relate to sampling from the discrete
Gaussian but over ships of the lattice
so no was talking about the discrete
Gaussian over sort of the central shift
of the lattice in the previous talk and
you know we'll discuss briefly what you
can expect in terms of what you need to
sample at what parameter do you need to
sample to sort of get a corresponding
good approximation factor then we'll
talk about the the shifted version of
our dgs sampler which in the mechanics
will be essentially identical to the
previous sampler but the analysis of the
loss factor is much much more technical
or well it's more technical and then
this which is really a completely new
component is going to be related to the
fact that we're not going to be able to
solve the problem exactly by just
sampling and waiting to hit a closest
vector so in the previous talk if you
have the right parameter you would just
magically hit a or test lattice vector
with some you know none well reasonable
enough probability and here we're not
going to be able to do that and we're
going to have to essentially slowly
learn the coordinates of the closest
factor in cluster the approximate
closest vectors and use recursion and
yeah it gets a little bit messy so the
shift of discrete Gaussian is exactly
the same as the non shifted discrete
Gaussian in terms of
the definitions except that we have the
extra shift so it's supported on a shift
of the lattice as noah already showed in
previous pictures is the the parameter
they use goes down we get a more
concentrated Gaussian so hopefully
that's useful from the perspective of
getting approximations and you know just
to notice that if you want vectors that
are close to tea or closest to tea that
just corresponds to the shortest vectors
in the shift okay so it makes sense to
try and sample short vectors from from
this shifted lettuce and the main
question that you know we want to ask is
can we hit closest vectors if we sample
from the discrete Gaussian for small
enough parameters and so here you can
already see that maybe there's kind of a
small issue and the small issue is the
is the following which is that
essentially unlike SVP where you have
the the kissing number of bounds that
sort of tell you how many closest
vectors you can have shorter specters
you can have but also how many of you
sort of approximately shortest vectors
you can have that doesn't happen here
and the reason is because a sort of you
can have a target that's in space that's
whose distance is sort of proportional
to the kind of sparse parts of the
lattice so the distance is is you know
really controlled by this large gap but
all of these vectors of which you know
if I make this x-axis smaller I can have
arbitrarily many of them will all be
very good approximate closest vectors so
so the the issue that we're going to
have to deal with is that you know I
mean unless we sampled from really
really tiny parameters we don't really
expect to be able to exactly hit this
guy or this guy but you know will be
somewhere in here okay
on the other end okay so what can we
expect so this is something that we
prove using some standard tale bounds
for the discrete Gaussian which is when
we when we look at the shifted discreet
Gaussian and we have it at you know the
the following parameter how big will
it's you know squared norm B and what we
can show is that essentially it will be
you know as small as it could possibly
be so this is the squared distance to
the target plus you know some sort of
variance term which is kind of intrinsic
to the Gaussian you know having
essentially this type of squared squared
norm at that parameter so this the
continuous Gaussian would ok this is off
by a factor and would roughly have this
as the expected squared norm so you'll
get something here it's kind of
interesting in some sort of squared
additive approximation but it's it's
quite it's quite good and it more or
less only depends on on the parameter s
and dimension and this can be turned
into like a real approximation factor so
if d is the distance you'll get sort of
this approximation ratio which basically
means that as long as d sorry as long as
s is smaller than something like epsilon
times D you'll get you know whatever
kind of I mean you'll get a good enough
approximation but we won't really be a
like focused too much on the details of
this because we're going to be able to
solve the problem exactly anyway
regardless now we know that you know if
we can sample the discrete Gaussian from
low enough parameters then we can get
pretty good approximations and you know
that will just depend on how s relates
to the distance to the target so now let
me define a short basis or a kind of a
canonical type of short basis that is
used in lattice algorithms all over the
place and we
need this for initialization purposes as
well as for a recursive algorithm so for
a basis B we're going to define the kind
of gram-schmidt projections so the I've
projection will project orthogonal to
the first I minus 1 vectors and then
from there you can define the
gram-schmidt orthogonalization which
just takes every vector and projects it
orthogonal to the previous ones and from
here you can now define what's known as
a hermit quirk in zolotarev or HK z
basis which is essentially a very greedy
type of basis where you're trying to
build a basis which has the shortest
vector as possible and how do you build
it you essentially first pick the
shortest factor of the lattice then you
look at the lattice projected orthogonal
to the first vector and you pick the
shortest vector in that and put that as
part of your basis you have to lift it
but it doesn't really matter for us how
you do that and you continues
successively and this is computable with
n calls to a shorter Specter Oracle
which we know how to do from the
previous talk ok so this will be what
one of the things that we'll we'll use
and we start with so what are the
guarantees for our sampler so here
things will be slightly more tricky than
in the previous talk because we won't
actually be able to sample from
arbitrary parameters or at least not
with the basic algorithm but what will
we be able to do so if we have a
parameter that's bigger than this
slightly sub exponential factor times
the the length of the largest
gram-schmidt vector in your basis then
then we can generate samples from the
discrete Gaussian the shifted one that
we want the number of samples will be
slightly more complicated so before we
just had sort of 2 to the N over 2
roughly that we could guarantee at each
stage if you ignore sort of extra kind
of factors based on you know us trying
to get a small statistical distance and
this number is the inverse probability
of hitting the heaviest bucket of the
the shifted lattice mod two times itself
so this this is the same buckets that we
had in the previous talk and all will be
able to guarantee is that we essentially
can produce enough samples to hit the
heaviest bucket and if you run this a
few times so even you know roughly we
will be running it subjects financially
many times you'll be able to hit all the
like nearly heaviest buckets and this is
where you you sort of expect the closest
vector to live or in one of the heavy
buckets because the closest vector 2t
will have the maximum kind of energy in
some sense i mean the gaussian massive
the closest vector is going to be higher
than any other single vector but
obviously in a bucket there are many
many vectors so so it's not you know
exactly like this and we can do this in
in in two to the end time okay so first
thing to note is that if if the distance
to the target is sort of a little bit
bigger than the basis / some polynomial
the length of the basis / some
polynomial then just one sample from
this distribution actually gives you you
know a ridiculously good approximation
and this is not that hard to achieve you
need to do some pre-processing you know
restrict to the appropriate sub lattice
to be able to achieve this but you know
this this obviously looks amazingly good
but even with this it'll be quite a fair
amount of work to turn this into an
exact algorithm and you know more
importantly I mean not worrying about
the details of how you get the
approximation this Sam
its own will suffice to get the exact
closest victory okay so now let me talk
about you know some of the technical
details related to our combiner in the
same way as we had in the in the
previous talk so here basically what
Noah showed in the previous talk holds
in full generality which is that if you
take two gaussians on different shifts
of the of the lattice and you look at
you know sort of conditioning the
average to land inside also the lattice
but now with the appropriate shift which
is the average of these two shifts then
you get exactly the distribution that
you want IE this probability is
proportional to the Gaussian mass or the
the Gaussian weight with the parameter
divided by square root 2 in exactly the
same way as we wanted and had before and
the only extra thing that I wanted to
say is ok we still have this similar
identity this is the you know the proof
that Noah showed you by rotating this 2
n dimensional lattice and this identity
is actually going to allow us to prove
some really amazing inequalities which
you know none of which we really
understand but essentially there were
many times where you know we got we got
stuck and then divesh who's you know the
one of the main authors on this paper
like figured out how to you know use
these identities to get some other
magical inequality to come out which
made everything work out so this this
thing is quite powerful so ok how do we
do the combining so it's very similar as
we had before so we have our
initialization so we need to kind of get
enough samples to start with and here to
do the initialization in the same way as
know described before but here we'll
start with a very strong
initialization will start with our HK z
basis and then we'll use standard
methods such as you know those due to
gentrify curve I come to nothing to
sample at large parameters but large is
already going to be sort of the maximum
parameter you know this size of the
gram-schmidt of the largest crimp
Schmidt of the basis okay and then the
meta procedure as before is going to be
a sampling from this kind of squared
collision probability and then you know
thinking unused samples that lie inside
that bucket averaging them and taking
them out of the list and repeating so
this is essentially the same procedure
that Noah described and now the only
difference is going to be at least the
techniques that we need to use to bound
the loss factor so the loss factor is
going to be or you know it's going to
essentially determine how many samples
we can get out of this in the next step
and as before you know the loss factor
should essentially be the
proportionality factor which you know
another way to see it compared to what
Noah road is that this L should be
chosen so that you don't exhaust the
sort of supply of samples you have at
least on expectation and again this is
going to be controlled by the heaviest
cosset so if you look at the inequality
it's going to be the hardest to satisfy
it's going to be the one that has the
the largest Gaussian mass and you get
from that once you plug in the heaviest
weight cosset the following
funky-looking loss factor and the
magical thing that we can prove so this
will be quite different than the
previous analysis is that the product of
the loss factors in this case is
going to be this 2 to the minus n so
before we head to the minus sent over to
here I'm adding a factor based on the
fact that we at least for every sample
we killed two samples in the previous
stage because we're averaging so I mean
no I didn't write that but this is just
to let you know that that's one of the
fundamental reasons that we can't do
this like an infinite number of times
and we get exactly this inverse weight
of the heaviest bucket so to be able to
go K steps given you know this loss
factor bound we need to start with at
least two to the K vectors you know plus
enough just to guarantee that we can
average k times and I'm not going to
prove this where it turns out that you
know so this telescoping product that we
had in the in the previous setting is
not what we have here and mainly the
reason is because the heaviest bucket at
the case stage changes so at every stage
we get different heaviest buckets
potentially and so you need a way to
relate the weight of the heaviest bucket
in a previous stage to the weight of the
heaviest bucket in the next stage and
this is sort of what this inequality
does it was quite simple to prove but I
won't you know go through the proof it
does use our magical identity and and
more or less that's that's it with one
very simple inequality so that if you
have this inequality you can prove the
bound on the loss factor if you fiddle
around with it but let's move now to how
we actually try and solve the exact
closest vector problem so from the the
sampler that works at you know really
small parameters we can get very good
approximate solutions but we can't get
exact solutions but still however
there's hope for how we can figure out
where the closest vector must be because
you can already see in this example that
all of the vectors that
are going to get all of the approximate
closest vectors that we're going to get
lie on two subspaces okay so somehow you
do know that the closest vector is
either here or here you don't quite know
where but it's here it's either there
there and a very powerful tool to kind
of start to understand how this is is is
happening this kind of clustering is
again by looking at the parodies of
vectors but now in a completely
different context so we're going to look
at two sort of approximate closest
vectors so two vectors x and y that are
at this distance from T so a little bit
more than you know the exact distance
and then we're going to assume that they
have the same parity and then it turns
out and this is more or less has a well
it doesn't have a proof by picture but
at least the intuition is clear that
these two vectors x and y if they're
very very close to T and they have the
same parity then it means that the
average since the average is in the
lattice has to have a pretty large
length right because this length of the
average is going to be at least you know
the length of this is going to be at
least this distance so if you have two
vectors on the sphere and you average
them and the norm doesn't decrease by a
lot then they have to be very very close
to each other on the sphere and perhaps
is somewhat surprising thing though this
is really a simple algebra is that you
can prove that the distance between them
depends only on this kind of extra r
squared factor okay so the fact that
this is independent from the distance to
the target is quite it's quite important
and enables a lot of what we can show so
i won't go i mean the proof of this is
just algebra but i won't go through it
and now already directly from this I
mean this you could see perhaps I mean
it's the same picture it's even easier
the parody is quite important so using
pie
a priority argument which I'll do here
you can see that for any lattice in a
new target you can only have exam oast
to to the end closest vectors to you
know any target and it's trivially tight
I mean just take the all one house
vector in the integer lattice and all
the corners of the cube are going to be
closest factors but by the the previous
lemma the easy way to see this is that
if you take any two closest factors and
if you assume that they have the same
parity the previous lemma will tell you
that they have distant zero from each
other and so they are the same and since
their utmost to to the end you know
distinct parodies you have a 2 to the N
bound now slightly less trivial but also
quite quite simple is we can use this to
do dimension reduction so what we can
show is the following so let's start
with our HK z basis that we computed at
the beginning let's assume that we're in
the same setting so we have you know x
and y their approximate closest vectors
and they have the same parity then if
you can show that you know so the
distance is extra r squared distance
that they are from from the minimal
distance to t is smaller than the length
of one of your basis vectors in your HK
z basis then if you express x and y if
you express their coordinates with
respect to the basis this is chosen so
that their last k coordinates with
respect to the basis are identical so
they have to have the same last k
coordinates so this sort of means that
at some point if you look at approximate
closest vectors of the same parity there
the last k coordinates with respect to
an HK z basis is frozen so you you all
the interesting sort of action that
happens afterwards occurs on the other
coordinates which is how we can start to
think about doing recursion and this
also has a very simple proof so hero
I'll go through with it so basically I
just need to show that the the last k
coordinates with the scat with respect
to the the basis are equal which is
equivalent to showing that if I sort of
project onto the last cave basis vectors
that X minus y is 0 and if this isn't
the case then we know that because they
have the same parody this is a lattice
vector so it's in particular after I
project it in the in the projection of
the lattice with respect to this
projection and it's non zero because I'm
assuming it's non zero and this is the
whole proof so the the projection norm
is smaller than the norm of the vector
this is smaller than R by the previous
lemma and by our assumption are smaller
than this which is the length of the
shortest vector in this lattice so you
have a vector whose length is small a
nonzero vector in a lattice whose length
is smaller than the length of the
shortest nonzero vector so that's a
contradiction so that that basically
shows that you you have this kind of
freezing phenomenon and so that won't
actually be enough to do recursion in a
useful way but it'll be close to what we
need really what we need will
essentially be the following so we're
going to show or we show in the paper
that if you start with an h kz basis
then just staring at the the lengths of
the basis vectors so i'll be looking at
the geometry in essence of the basis
vectors that i can choose a k which will
correspond to the last K vectors in the
basis so that no matter what the the
target is I'll be able to ensure that
with our sampler that we had in in the
middle of the talk that'll be able to
learn the last k coordinates of an exact
closest vector ok
and this so this is something that will
be a property just of the basis that I
won't have to know the target I can just
look at the basis look at how the
lengths of the the length of the basis
vectors changes and i'll be able to
pinpoint a spot where i can say okay
after this spot i'll be able to learn
all of the coefficients of the closest
vector so more precisely the way this is
really going to happen is that we'll be
able to show that if we look at any
close enough vector to t for the k that
we've chosen the actual exact
coordinates where the yeah the exact
coordinates with respect to the last K
vectors will be essentially completely
determined by the parody of the
coordinates so since the if these are
determined by their parity then I can
only have at most sort of 2 to the K
different options of what I see here now
this won't be exactly true but it'll be
true enough to make the algorithm work
so the idea from this is basically that
will be able to group the approximate
closest vectors by what their last k
coefficients are with respect to your HK
z basis these will index if what I said
previously is correct 2 to the K shifts
of the sub lattice span by the first n
minus K vectors and that's where in one
of those shifts you have to have the
exact closest vector so so you get 2 to
the K shifts which gives you 2 to the K
sub problems which are of dimension n
minus K so that that should hopefully
work and this is essentially how that
works you know in the picture that I've
been showing before that if you look at
the approximate closest vectors their co
efficient with their parody of the the
basis the parody of their coordinate
with respect to the last basis vector
essentially determines where the vector
is so here the parodies even and we say
we see that it has to be anything that's
approximate closest vector and II
on the second basis vector has to be on
this line and the odds have to be on
this line okay so the final like high
level algorithm is you know we compute
our HK z basis we sample we figure out
how many coordinates we expect to learn
of the exact closest vector we sample a
whole bunch of approximate closest
vectors using the sampling algorithm
from the middle of the talk we group
them according to their last k
coordinates and recurse this is
essentially you know the whole the whole
algorithm so stated this way I think it
looks simple enough obviously the
details are painful and in terms of the
complexity that you know this will like
the way we more or less analyze this is
the following so the initialization
phase where we compute the basis that's
due to the end time each level so if
we're at a level where the demand the
lattice is n dimensional we take a 2 to
the end time and for the recursion we
were cursed on roughly two to the K sub
problems of dimension n minus K so when
you work it all out you get exactly two
to the end time and the key challenge is
that some of them i looted too and some
of them I didn't so most of them here
I'm more or less alluded to so you know
how you get the dgs samples efficiently
that we more or less talked about how we
show that the last k coefficients are
determined by their parody what I showed
you is that if you look at the parody of
all n coefficients then you know what
the last k coefficients are if you have
an approximate closest vector but here
we need that the parody of the last k
coefficients gives you exactly what the
last k coefficients are so that's a
different a slightly different story we
don't always get exactly 2 to the K sub
problems if we did always get exactly 2
to the K sub problems of dimension and
minus K it would be trivial but
essentially we show that we do get
exactly 2 to the K sub problems as long
as
is small and was K is large we get a
little deviation off of this but somehow
we make so much progress on decreasing
the dimension that it ends up not
mattering and the last thing I didn't
show you and this is intuitively not so
bad but the the proof I mean we have no
intuition for why the proof works is
that we actually have to show that we
eventually hit the last k coefficients
of an exact closest vector so all of
what I've been showing you up until this
point is basically convincing you that
our algorithm should probably terminate
into to the end time but not that it
will actually find the exact closest
vector and the reason it does is because
we'll be able to show that you know for
the right choice of parameter the
discrete Gaussian will actually hit the
bucket containing the exact closest
vector so it will hit a bucket that has
the same parity as the exact closest
vector and that will allow us to find
the last k coefficients and you know the
intuition as to why that should be true
is somehow because the closest vector
should make the bucket very heavy but
the proof doesn't show you that
intuition unfortunately so the
conclusions so we have the fastest
algorithm for for CDP so that's 2 to the
N time what's interesting is that we
actually kind of explicitly and
sometimes implicitly use ideas from all
the previous algorithms so I mean we
really use the properties of HK z basis
as in you know basis reduction
algorithms we make a sort of massive
improvement on the approximation
guarantees that saving algorithms were
able to get and that was very crucial
and then in terms of with respect to the
Voronoi based methods I mean the the
high-level comparison that is is is very
perhaps misleading but I'm curious to
understand what it means is that we rely
very crucially on all this parody
information and
that's exactly how you bound the number
of vectors in the Voronoi cell so I'm
not quite sure if there's any real
relationship there other than
superficial and the final thing is that
you know the discrete Gaussian is
clearly you know shown itself to be a
very powerful tool I mean we've seen it
used first in pure math to prove all
sorts of inequalities about lattices
then encrypt 04 its statistical
properties and finally as an actual
algorithmic tool so you know I expect
more you know can come from analyzing
and in terms of the open problems I mean
is the algorithm in essence optimal
right so so I somehow feel like it'll be
unlikely for us to ever find an
algorithm that goes faster than 2 to the
end because the number of closest
vectors can be 2 to the end so at least
it's more or less output optimal but can
you can you find some assumption that
might justify this and here i would
really like to know if there's a
deterministic or at least you know Las
Vegas algorithm that doesn't need
randomness and this is a picture that's
showing essentially the the Voronoi cell
or and its neighbors and actually showed
improving some of the work of magento
vulgaris that once you know the vectors
of the Voronoi cell you can actually
solve CVP into to the end time but there
too to the end of these vectors and it
takes 2 to the M time to find each of
them so that's 4 to the n but I was very
surprised that like we didn't end up
saying anything with respect to the
Voronoi cell in this paper and third I
mean I think the algorithm is too
complicated and yeah I really like to
see a simpler and cleaner algorithm so
thank
you think this kind of problem may also
be the single exponential time algorithm
for interactivity in l1 oh well the
issue the issue with that is we really
this clustering property based on parity
is you know I mean we're really a were
you well but even even with a not that
notwithstanding the the problem is you
know all of our dimension reduction
tricks are based on really saying that
if you know two vectors of the same
parity and their approximate closest
vectors then they must be very close to
each other and this doesn't hold you
know when you don't have strict
convexity any I mean what we're using is
much stronger than strict convexity I
mean we you know we have this algebraic
relation which exactly tells us what the
what the distance between the vectors
should be so I yeah I mean maybe if the
norm is strictly convex but even then
it's unclear
ok